Well, home from the movies at last.
Looks like it, Aunt Mattle.
Hi, Dad!
Hello, Son!
Well, daughter, how was
the movie pictured tonight?
Hmm.
Lovely.
Right, that's what it
was. Just a lot of mud.
There wasn't anybody
killed in the whole thing.
No, well then, I'll stick
to these, these don't talk.
Well, that big clock, Norman
Maine was in the pictures tonight,
he never does anything
but kiss a lot of girls.
Norman Maine, is one of
the best actors in pictures.
You and your movies.
That's all that you think about.
You shouldn't be allowed to
go to them at all, if you ask me.
Too bad I was so busy in the kitchen.
And I didn't hear anybody asking you.
Hello, Granny!
Hello, Darling
And off course no one ever listens to me!
They do if they're within ten miles of ya.
Gathering around picture shows,
house all covered up with movies magazines.
And the other day I caught her
talking to a horse with a Swedish accent!
Well, Sis...
you're only young once, you know?
Ah!
Hollywood!
You'd better be getting yourself a good
husband and stop mooning about Hollywood.
You know what she wants to do?
She wants to go to Hollywood!
I've noted all along.
I've seen her making faces in
the mirror and talking to herself
That's what comes of your movies!
Why? What would you do
if you did go to Hollywood?
I'd be an actress.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I would, I tell ya, I've
always known I could.
Guys, wouldn't it be wonderful to have a movie star in
the family? Oh, Miss Blodgett, may I have your autograph?
You may not know it Aleck, but
you're practically on your way to bed.
Oh, Miss Blodgett you're my favorite actress,
wouldn't you tell me the secret of your success?
Oh, let me alone!
Why Esther, what's come over you?
I'll tell you what's come over her.
She's just a silly little girl whose
head is been turned by the movies
And as soon as she forgets the
whole thing, the better off she'll be.
Oh, why will I be better off?
What's wrong with want to go out and make something
of myself? What do you do that's so much better?
Just because you're satisfied to sit here
all your life, you think you can laugh at me!
Well, some day you won't laugh at me! I'm going
out and have a real life! I'm gonna be somebody!
Now if it was spring, I'd say give her
a good dose of sulfur and molasses.
I thought I'd find you up.
Oh, stop that!
Now stop crying! that isn't
going to do you a bit good.
I'm crying because Aunt
Mattie and Aleck make so mad.
Well, it's your aunt Mattie, Aleck.
They're not important.
You're the only one that counts.
Esther, everyone in this world who
has ever dreamed about better things
has been laughed at, don't you know that?
Oh, I suppose I do, but...
But there's a difference
between dreaming and doing.
The dreamers just sit around and moon
about how wonderful it would be
if only things were different.
And the years roll on and they grow old
and by and by they forget everything,
even about their dreams.
I don't want to be like that,
I want to be somebody,
Oh yes, oh yes.
You want to be somebody,
but you want it to be easy.
Oh, you modern girls give me a pain!
When I wanted something better,
I came across those planes in
the prairies... with your Grandfather.
Oh, everyone laughed at us, like
they did with the other pioneers.
They said this country will never
be anything but a wilderness.
We didn't believe that.
We were going to make a new country.
Besides,
we wanted to see our dreams come true.
Oh Granny, it must have been wonderful.
It was wonderful.
But don't you think for one single
minute that it was easy, Esther Blodgett.
We burned in summer and we froze in winter.
But we kept right on going
and we didn't complain.
Because we were doing what we wanted to do!
Can you understand that?
Yes, I can.
Could you do it?
Could you do it even
if it broke your heart?
Because remember Esther,
for every dream of yours
you make come true,
you'll pay the price in heartbreak.
I know what I'm talking about.
You may not believe it,
but I was a young girl once.
A very pretty young girl,
a lot prettier than you are.
I was in love with your grandfather,
and when some indian
devil put a bullet through him,
I felt like it had come
straight through my heart too.
I remembered all he taught me
and I went right on him.
I buried him out there on that wilderness
with my own hands.
I went right on that same day
And I kept right on the way,
even when your mother was born.
Oh Granny, I would make it worthwhile.
You know, Esther,
there'll always be a wilderness to conquer.
Maybe Hollywood is your wilderness now.
From all I hear,
it sounds like it.
But if you've got one drop
of my blood in your veins,
you won't let Mattie or any
of her kind break your heart,
you'll go right out there
and break it yourself.
That's your right.
Here.
Oh, here, here, stop that nonsense.
Take this and go to your Hollywood.
Oh, I can't take you money.
Well, why not?
It's your savings!
Well, I was only saving up for my funeral.
Now I don't think I'm ever going to die.
Oh, granny, how can I ever thank you?
By giving me your word of honor
that you'll never tell a living soul
where you got that money.
I promise.
Remember, if you do,
I'll have you arrested for robbing me.
Here we are.
Want me to help you, Granny?
Oh, I can make it, Dear.
Oh!
Man, it's cold, uh.
I kissed Dad goodbye,
just a little kiss, he didn't even wake up.
I bet you didn't try that
on your Aunt Mattie.
Oh, Aunt Mattie...
Think of her face when you tell her.
I am thinking about it.
I've waited for that
chance for thirty years.
Fresh air
Oh, thank you Grelsy.
Girls, eh?
Come on, come on!
Look, there is you train.
All aboard!
Oh, Granny!
Come on, come on! go on! go on!
Good bye Granny!
Good bye!
I'll be waiting for you in
those movies pictures.
And don't tell Mattie,
you know my eyes are not
as good as they used to be,
But my ears are alright.
So you remember, talk up good and loud.
All aboard!
Goodbye!
Goodbye Granny!
Goodbye.
Do you want to go home now?
I don't want to
but I will.
Good Afternoon.
Day, week or month?
But it's a little hard to say you see,
I'm going into the movies.
Well you better take it for a week,
it'll break your jump to Beverly Hills.
Are all the studios really near here?
All except Gramon British.
I suppose the best way to get a job
is to go straight to the studios, isn't it?
I have many illusions you know, I
am perfectly willing to begin with...
ooh a little bit of a part,
or even as an extra.
$6 please
in advance.
Oh.
I beg your pardon,
I'd like to register for extra work.
How long have you been in Hollywood?
Well, it's about a month now.
We haven't put anyone on
our books for over two years.
Come here,
I'd like to show you something.
- Try later.
- No can't be, try later.
- Try later, thank you.
- Not now, try later.
Every time you see one of those little
lights flash it's somebody asking for a job.
Every time you hear them say: "Try later",
it means there isn't any job.
Can't keep the girls at the
switchboard long, they'd go crazy.
Every one of those little lights
thought it was going to be a star.
Still wanna go in the movies?
You know what your chances are?
One in a hundred thousand.
Maybe...
I'm that one.
Any phone calls for me, Mr. Randall?
Oh, no.
Jesse L. Lasky and Sammy Goldwyn
must be writting letters instead.
How was the luck today?
There wasn't any.
Maybe you don't go at in the right way
Now take Danny McGuire here, he
knows the ropes. Don't you Danny?
Sure, I've had 'em
around my neck for years.
What?
Oh, Miss Blodgett,
Danny McGuire, our new tenant
How do you do?
Mr. McGuire is a...
big director.
Oh.
Are you really?
Oh, could you possibly use
me in a picture, Mr. McGuire?
Of course I haven't had much experience but
I don't think that really
matters if you're willing.
- And I'm...
Now listen, lady.
In the first place I'm not a
director, I'm an assistant director
and the second place
if I had any jobs to give away,
I'd confirm one of them myself.
And in the third place, you should
have stayed back home in the first place!
Oh, no! Look what you've done.
Hey, wait a minute!
Hey, don't be that way!
Don't do that.
Gosh, I didn't mean to get tough.
A guy thinks he's being kidded when
somebody asking for a job and,
he hasn't got one for himself.
After all, I'm not a big enough shot to
hurt your feelings.
I'm sorry.
It wasn't just that, oh,
it was a lot of things.
I've been for a job everyday
and never getting any nearer to it.
I guess I was beginning
to get a little scared.
I know.
Lady, do I know.
Well, There's only one thing
to do when you're feeling
tired and sunk and
down to your last nickle.
Come on and I'll buy you a drink.
Well its not as bad as
down to the last nickle
I've still got $11 left.
$11 dollars!
You're gonna buy me a drink! Come on!
That's right George
there's nothing like a little rum to
take away that milk flavor.
I beg your pardon.
Certainly.
And when I sign my contract, the first thing I'm gonna
do is see that you direct every picture that I'm in.
Thats my pal!
Of course I'm going to be
perfectly nice about it, but
I'll just insist.
Now that's the way to talk.
Don't let 'em lick ya.
They can't lick me,
If they anything like that well,
I just won't sign.
Now that's right.
What have you got to lose?
Another one of these and
we'll open our own studio.
Bill rendered,
twenty four dollars.
Past due.
Remit without further delay.
Me.
Poor kid.
If she can't pay the bills she gets
No.
Fifth race, fifth race, I
can't... I can't believe it...
Hey! The program is gonna be swell tonight.
Now you take this fella Beethoven:
I'm a pushover for him.
And Chopin -
well, he's not so dusty, either.
But I kinda wish that once in awhile that
play something you
could sorta go out whistling.
You know, like "Blood
on the saddle, blood on..."
well now there's a tune
Hey, why don't you throw your hat
in the air or something. Can't you?
But this is a celebration,
my job starts tomorrow
I know it does, and I
think it's swell, Danny.
Gee, I wish you were in on it too.
But oh no, it would
have to be a war picture.
A big novelty number. The war picture
without any beautiful women at the front.
Oh well, something'll happen soon.
Maybe.
Why don't you go home kid?
Oh Danny, I can't do that.
I came here and I've got to stay.
Well now, if it's on
account of money I can...
Thank you but you given enough already
Anyhow this is no time to
be worrying, this is a party!
Look at all the people.
Everybody in the world,
Look
That's Norman Maine
seems to have had that one extra cocktail
Oh, Thank you.
Sit down you dope that's
for the orchestra leader.
Hello...
Hello, Norman.
Oh, Mr. Maine, Mr. Maine,
Put your arm around Miss Regis.
Arlow, this is the Hollywood Bowl.
Oh, afraid of crowds?
Go ahead, go on, Get outta here!
What's the matter? You getting
too big to bother with photographers?
Don't want any pictures taken now.
Oh is that so? Well
supposing I take it anyway
I'll shove that Brownie Number
2 of yours down your throat.
Thank you! Mr. Maine!
No! Stop it!
No!
Stop it!
No, Stop!
Come on!
Take it easy, Mr. Maine!
Hey, take your hands off.
Calm down, please.
Norman! come back and sit
down everybody's laughing at you.
Alright, already...
Hi, Norman.
Is he always like that?
Well, I suppose he has to sleep sometime.
Oh and he is so wonderful on the screen.
And thanks again, dear
Granny, for the money -
but you mustn't keep sending it.
Everything is going beautifully now.
In fact, Daniel McGuire, the director,
says I'm certain to get a job very soon.
Come in.
Hello, Danny.
What's the matter?
Belive it or not, I've got a job for you.
Ah!
Danny, that's wonderful!
When do I go to the studio?
Well, you don't exactly
know there's a studio.
Oh! It's on location.
No, it's not exactly on location.
Of course I haven't any makeup. Will you tell
me what to get and sort of help me put it on?
Well, you don't exactly need any makeup,
you see it's not really a picture job
it's, it's well it's being a waitress.
Oh.
Well it's kind of a picture
job if you look at it right.
But you said it was a waitress.
Well, it's waitressing for Casey Burt.
He's a big director over at our
studio, he's giving a party tonight
to kind of celebrate on
account of finishing the picture
and he wanted me to get him
an extra waitress and it's 5 dollars.
And I thought of you right away, Esther.
That was awfully sweet of you Danny.
Well,
They're gonna be a lot of
big people at Burke's house
I'll bet you there's any
number of big directors
and if you're there
maybe they'll notice you.
I could make them notice me.
Sure you could Ester! It's your chance!
My chance.
Alright Danny I'll do it, oh
but I can't, I haven't got
the right things to wear.
Oh! Oh! Here!
You don't think the wardrobe department is
right next to my office for nothing, do you?
Haha a perfect fit!
Did you get to the preview last night?
I did.
Vould you like a little hors d'oeuvre?
They are very nice.
Well thanks.
What did you think of the picture?
You should have saved it for Thanksgiving.
What a turkey!
Will you have some hors d'oeuvres?
You do like hors d'oeuvres don't you?
I don't think there's anything so
enjoyable as hors d'oeuvres before supper
And these are really delightful.
And at the finish, the kid turns
around and sings a lullaby to its mother.
Pardon me, big boy
but, would you like a
little, hors d'oeuvres?
They say they're the best.
In town.
Don't tell me.
I know.
Mae West.
That's a great twist! But where are you gonna
find a two month old baby that can sing?
Hello, Oliver!
Oh, hello Casey!
Wanna fire me now or
wait till you see the picture?
I'm not a director anymore I'm a...
male nurse!
What's the matter with the picture?
A guy by the name of Norman Main
His work is beginning to
interfere with his drinking.
Oliver,
don't tell me I'm to direct his next picture, too.
- Mhm
You were my favorite producer.
Now wait a minute, you just
go right on with your directing.
I'll take care of these stars.
I know how to handle them.
I had a serious talk with Norman after that
Hollywood Bowl occurrence.
And you not have to worry
any more about his behavior.
Excuse me, Mister Niles.
Mr Libby, of your publicity
department is on the telephone.
He says it's most important Sir.
It's about Mr. Maine.
Thank you.
Oh, it's probably just some little thing.
Of course, Oliver!
I´ll turn on the radio and see
If he's called out the National Guard yet.
Hello Libby, what´s the good word?
Mister Norman Maine,
America's prince charming,
Was apprehended driving an ambulance
Down Wilshire Blvd!
With a siren going full blast
He explained he was a tree
surgeon on a maternity case.
Well... er, will it be in the papers?
No it won't be in the papers.
But that's a nice expensive hobby of yours.
Keeping Mr. Maine's informal
entertainment out of the public press.
Oh, that´s fine work Libby
Try and see that no one gets to Norman.
He's probably home sleeping it off.
Because you forgot those
dopes at the studio for one night
Business, business all the time.
I dont know what´s gonna become of you
Norman!
Why didn't you call for me?
Oh my darling why didn't I call for you?
In case you've forgotten, I was
supposed to come here with you.
Oh that old hat's alright, I
got here without any trouble.
The only reason I don't slap your face...
Yes, yes, darling. I-I know.
Hello John!
Oh. Hello, Norman!
What's the matter with Oliver?
He looks as if he got bad news.
Hello!
Hello Larry.
What's the matter, old boy?
Maybe I'm wrong.
I guess I've been drinking too much lately.
Oh you ought to cut
that down, it's bad stuff
Scotch and soda
Come on, come on, come on.
The word you know, is pronounced 'when'.
Bad dialog Oliver.
Would rather not watch this
You know best
Soda!
Thank you!
Uh.
Go ahead and say it.
Got it coming to me.
Don't make it tougher on me Norman.
I don't want to stand here and preach,
but take a look at my side of it,
I'm trying to make pictures with you
I know, I know.
Costs are going up and
the grosses are going down.
No, it isn't that.
I made lots of money with you.
And I can afford to take a loss,
but I hate to see you going
the way of so many others.
Why don't you get Lloyds
to insure you against me?
You can't get insurance against
a man forgetting who he is.
You're a great star Norman, but there's nobody so big
they can afford to have people refuse to work with him.
Who doesn't wanna work with me? You...
Quiet.
Listen, I know plenty people who do.
Yes and so do I
but your real friends can't stand
seeing you start to fall apart.
What do you mean by that?
First signs are always the same
not being able to remember your lines.
Camera man struggling
to cover your hangovers
And all because you
have to have a good time...
every day and every night.
Listen I've warned you for a long time.
I know, Oliver you're a swell guy,
you won't lose any money on me.
I'll promise you that.
I'll be ready for the curtains
when the time comes.
When it does,
Here's my epitaph.
Good for amusement only.
Now I think I'll um...
have another drink.
Scotch and soda
Scotch and Soda.
Come on, come on, come on.
A little soda.
Caviar?
No, thanks.
Yes, um pardon me.
Lovely, lovely.
I mean caviar.
Oh don't, don't go away, I'm starving.
Which... which would you take?
Oh, I don't know.
You don't know? I... I don 't know either.
Hard to choose.
But I think I'll take, caviar.
Mr. Maine doesn't care for anymore.
Do you, Norman?
No.
No, Normy doesn't care for anymore.
I think I shall get very drunk indeed.
Scotch and soda.
Sorry, I have something.
Oh.
Mind if I help you?
Won't they miss you?
Oh no no, they'll just look under
the table and when they see
I'm not there they'll
forget the whole matter.
What... er?
What... what's your name?
Esther Blodgett.
My name is Maine.
I know.
You do?
What, What's so funny?
I was just thinking about all your fans
and how surprised they'd be to see
you here helping me put plates away.
Oh they don't know my finest side.
They'd be pretty envious of me
meeting you this way in person.
Oh, how'd you do?
So Tell me eh, eh,
Are you disappointed?
Yes.
Oh.
Now you've done it.
Oh never mind that, that
makes the room look lived in.
Tell me um
wh-
why are you disappointed?
I was sitting behind you,
at the Hollywood Bowl the night you
didn't want to be photographed.
Oh.
I'm told I crept in to
many a heart that night
Oh I can never explain this.
You know you have very pretty hair.
You better get out of here.
A sensitive mouth,
and a charming little-
Can't see why you're here
instead of with the rest of the guests
I was just trying to be helpful.
I see.
Are you sure there's no other attraction?
Well it might be that my old mania for
putting plates away is coming back on me.
It's rather odd. I always
know where I can find you.
If there's a pretty girl around.
It's not only odd, it's embarrassing.
You're being deliberately insulting Norman.
I put up with you for long enough-
Now dear don't lose your temper.
Remember we must try to keep the voice low.
I know you'll excuse us
if we go on with our work.
Now see what you've done!
Come here.
Help me up.
Are you hurt?
No more than usual.
Come on! The wolves are
on us we gotta get outta here.
I can't! The dishes aren't finished!
Oh yes they are!
Well,
I bet I know what you're gonna say now.
What?
Good night.
Good night and thanks.
Hey wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Hey, Uh...
Here.
You realize that
all I found out about you is that you're
foolish enough to want to go into pictures?
Why the foolish, look at you.
Oh, that's what I mean.
No I'd
I'd rather like to go into this
matter a little more thoroughly.
Well that's awfully nice of you.
Why um
why don't we uh go on up to my place and
talk it over?
Oh, no.
Thank you very much, but
I really must say goodnight.
Goodnight.
You're not angry.
No no no.
I'm hungry.
Well, why don't you go
and get something to eat?
Goodnight, Miss Blodgett.
Goodnight, Mr. Maine.
Wait a minute.
Least I can do is to see you to your door.
Will I see you again?
I hope so.
Has anyone ever told
you that you're lovely?
Well, now you know.
Thank you.
It's a...
It's hard to say, but I
I wanna say it anyway.
You know I'm a, I'm a screen, I'm a
you know
In private life, I'm a
You know...
but whatever I do I
still respect lovely things.
And you're lovely.
Do you understand?
Yes, I think I do.
And it isn't that bump on
the head that's doing this
I'm glad.
Goodnight.
Hey!
Do you mind if I take just one more look?
Go away!
Quite impossible.
I wouldn't even consider it!
Oh no no!
Hello?
Who is it?
Who?
Norman?!
What have you done now?
You're not in jail are you?
Ohh.
Yes, I see.
Oh it's that again.
I see.
She's beautiful.
I know, you want me
to give her a screen test.
Yeah?
Certainly, she's got
wonderful possibilities.
Oh, you know she's got something.
And you knew all the other
ones had something too
Oh no.
I tell you Oliver,
She's got that sincerity
and and honestness.
And uh, uh
uh sincerity and honestness
that uh that makes
great actresses
Oliver, I am so sure of this girl,
that I want to take the
test with her myself.
Hmm...
Listen Oliver, you've worked hard,
you're entitled to a break.
You get...
Yes. I heard you.
Anything. ANYTHING.
Yes!
Yes. Yeah.
Oliver, look,
You, you try to get a
little sleep now old man.
Right, alright boy.
Go-Good Night.
♪ Mumbles ♪
Telephone book
Telephone book.
Where's telephone bo..
There you are little telephone book!
Yes?
Telephone!
For me?
Some drunk trying to be
funny, says he's Norman Maine.
Oh, oh thanks I'll be right down.
And Miss Blodgett.
Would you give him the message for me?
Tell him it's 3 o'clock in the morning!
Hello?
What?
Ohh.
Ohh!
Oh..
Oh yes yes I'll be there!
Oh thank you!
Sigh
Danny... Danny...
Danny, what do you think? I'm going to take a
test tomorrow and Norman Maine's helping me do it!
I'm taking one too.
Garbo's assisting me.
♪ Groans♪ oh-
Move that go bow in
Put a silk on that thorn
No the...
Is this light too hot for you?
Ok..
We'll put that on the drive way..
Put a double on that 90
bring it down a little.
That's it.
Pull down on that 150
Pull down on that 150.
Give me an apple bucket.
Listen, gentlemen.
Please, if you don't mind.
This is... this is just a test.
Ready Mr. Burke
Ready now Mr. Burke
All ready Mr. Burke
Ready Mr. Burke
We're ready Mr. Burke
All right, let's take it
QUIET!
Quiet!
Quiet... quiet...
Quiet...
Ready Norman.
Yup.
Ready Miss uh, what's your name.
He'll soon know your name, Esther.
The whole world's going to know it.
But I'm so scared.
Maybe I'd better not try today.
Oh, come on, now don't be foolish.
They all had to go through this.
Harlow, Lombard, Myrna Loy.
And now,
Esther Blodgett.
Alright.
I'm ready.
This is a take.
Roll 'em.
Quiet!
Take
Oliver Niles Productions.
By Oliver Niles
Esther Victoria Blodgett
I may as well tell you
that my whole organization
thinks I've gone a little nuts
to sign you.
Maybe they are right,
I've been nuts before.
You see,
All the experts seems to think that your type
is a little mild for present day's taste.
I'd rather believe that
tastes change, like eyebrows.
And I think that also like eyebrows,
tastes are going back to the natural.
You look like a nice girl,
I think I'm going to like you.
That's not important.
I think the public will like you.
That is important.
Oh yes.
I see what you mean,
I - I mean I know it is.
But you don't think it's going to be easy
Nothing you really want
is ever given away free.
You have to pay for it.
And usually with your heart.
Someone else told me that once.
But you still have to
work it out for yourself.
Oh well, all this is just
a long way of saying
I'm glad you're with
us, and good luck to you.
Now, I'm going to turn you over
to our demon press agent, Libby.
Don't let him frighten you.
He has a heart of gold...
only harder.
And for the love of Pete,
learn to close your
mouth and keep it closed.
Even in your love scenes.
Are you a Russian?
No, I was born in Filmore North Dakota.
Oh no.
Grace saw light of day...
In a mountain cabin,
at trappers hut
High up in the rockies
Go on.
Well, I always wanted to be an actress.
Dreamed of footlights,
as lonely kitty
Are you sure theres no
Russian in your family?
Positive.
That's a shame.
Well, what does your father do?
He's a farmer.
Eh..
Social registeried Father
Fed up with hypocrisy
a 400...
sought wilderness for consolation.
There amidst the mountain flowers.
He raised another blossom.
His lovely little daughter.
What's your name?
Esther Victoria Blodgett.
Greatly appreciating your
attention in this matter, very surely...
do you know what her name is?
Esther Victoria Blodgett.
He will have to do something
about that right away
Esther Victoria Blodgett
Well, that Blodgett's definitely out.
Let's see, Esther Victoria
Victoria, Vicky. How about Vicky?
Oh I think that's terribly cute! let's
see, Vicky, Vicky what?
Vicky Vicky. Pronounced.
Vicky. Vicky.
Siesta, besta, sesta, desta, festa...
Oh, that's very pretty.
Hesta, hesta, Jesta, Lester, Vicky Lester!
Oh I like that!
Say it!
Vicki Lester
Say it again.
Say it!
Vicki Lester
say Vicki Lester!
Vicki Lester!
Lester.
Franz
Oliver Nile Studio discovers new starlet.
A Cinderella of the Rockies
Her name is Vicky Lester
Those who have peeked
tells me should couldn't be more divine
The face of an angel
and such natural talent
Her voice is a symphony.
Her very walk, they tell me
is enough to drive men mad!
Not that way!
Get the lead outta your feet! Lift them up!
That's better.
It's terrible, but it's better.
The quality of mercy is not strange
it droppeth as the gentle rain from heaven
Cease.
Through the mouth, my
child. Through the mouth.
The nose is for smelling roses.
Proceed.
Does she have to look
surprised all the time?
Anyway, it's just a rough sketch.
Pretty small mouth eh?
Oh well,
Give her that cloth a squeeze
ooh
This will give that xjssalhhfid
We are on the wrong track,
she still looks surprised.
Listen drunk people
My shoes not on the step this morning
not in the camera
now come on snap in to it!
Acme trrrrucking company.
No, Mister Smith is not in!
Acme trucking company.
No.
Mister Smith is not in.
Good morning, what
can I bring you Mr. Maine?
Just shows how long you've been here.
Never blushes.
How soon are you and I
going to be married huh?
I don't know.
You will have to ask my mother.
Acme trucking company.
No, Mister Smith is not in.
Acme...
Naw Shmith ain't in!
Acme trucking company.
I'd like to speak to Mr. Smith please.
Mister Smith is not...
Oh, Norman!
What's all this between you and Smith?
I got a part... It's only one line...
but it's in the Picture!
So it's ambition that made you
break that date with me last night.
I had to be here so early this morning.
Uh, so did I.
I had to stay up all night to make it.
You've started your picture, haven't you?
No, no we are still in the testing stage.
Can't seem to get the
right girl for the lead.
Hmm..You'd think with
all the girls there are...
Yeah, well this one's got to be different.
She's got to be little,
and cute, and sweet,
And intelligent.
Well blow me down.
What?
Well close my tired old eyes,
Wha..what is it?
Hold everything, come on.
Come on!
Have you been through
the whole casting, Director?
I'll work day and night Mr...
And I'll work with her Oliver!
I can mean or nasty or
anything you want, Mr Niles.
If she clicks Oliver,
you've got a star overnight.
Ok.
Wait till you hear them
at the end of the picture.
When the world tripped politely
to the genteel music of spinnets.
Do you think we were noticed?
No one... They're much
to busy playing at croquet.
I have loved you all my life.
But we have only met two days ago.
That's when my life began.
Ain't she cute?
You know I think she's the same
type I am. Don't you? I think she's sweet.
Well... has this picture...
all right!
I think she was much better than he was.
These producers are so horribly down...
They wont know how good she is...
Well maybe it's because she's a good girl.
All I mean is that it's not so bad..but
it's even less that I want to see.
Darling, I think she's the most
precious little thing I've ever-
She's a knock out Libby.
You might mention that
when you write your review.
Unless the kids' a gold mine.
Did you like Norman Maine?
Was he in it?
Libby?
I'm afraid we have another hit.
It's in the bag.
Deeply tied up with beautiful pink ribbons.
Hey, where are Norman and Vicky?
I don't know, I thought you had them.
I wish they'd come, were
having a party at the Trocadero.
Isn't it thrilling running
away from people?
Norman, it's so exciting! So-
- So-
- So new.
A star is born.
Come on!
Wonderful, isn't it?
A crazy quilt.
Well... It's a carpet spread for you...
All yours from now on you know.
You're a success
You can have everything
in the world you want.
Hope it'll make you happy.
Doesn't it you?
Well... That was one thing I never had...
Lots of times I..
I told myself I'd find it but
I always knew I was lying.
Still I... I never
stopped looking for it...
Maybe it'll come.
Well I think it has come Ester.
I only wish it weren't too late.
Oh but it's not too late.
Oh you can't throw away your
life the way I've thrown away mine.
I don't have anything left
that's good enough... now.
You can't...
Norman.. You can...
You mustn't tell me that, Esther.
So afraid that I'll believe it.
Pick your right!
Swell, isn't it?
Lovely.
Let's watch again.
He got ya... shoot your right!
Go!...He got him!
He did, didn't he?
Yeah, but he'll be up, though.
You like it?
Sure I do.
You like me?
That reminds me. Will you marry me?
No thank you.
Come on... finish him!
Why won't you marry me?
Because you're not dependable
Shoot your right!
You throw away your money.
Break him off!
And you drink so much.
Cause i quit drinking
Yes?
Come on... Shoot your
right in there... the right!!
Cause I save my money.
Yes.
There he goes!...Let him have it!!
I'm absolutely dependable
on all occasions... Yes...
Yeah!
He got ya... He got him... He got him!
He certainly did.
Yeah that was a beautiful fight!
Norman?
Yes dear?
Would you do all that for
me if I said I'd marry you?
No..certainly not... I'd just support you.
We're going to be married.
Guess I didn't read that line right.
I'll try it again.
We are going to be married.
Both of us.
To each other.
What do you think of that?
Well when? Where?
Oh, we thought that we'd elope
In a conventional manner.
What's the matter?
Trying to decide whether
it's good for the studio.
Is it?
It is.
Bless you my children.
When's it going to happen?
Oh we thought we'd
just sneak out some time.
W're not telling anyone but you.
Listen to this!
The squeeze ideal romance
blossomed into breathing reality
Today when Vicky Lester and Norman Maine,
America's dream lovers
Slipped quietly thru the
portals of holy matrimony.
How does it sound?
Horrible.
But you see we're going to elope.
Sure you are!
It will be the biggest
elopement this town ever saw.
We'll get a tie-up with the army
and have you escorted
all the way down to Yuma
by twenty of their new bombing planes.
Is he going with us?
Don't you think we can work
this thing out better alone?
No sense in bothering the
happy couple with all the details.
I'll see to it that you get a
carbon copy of the whole layout.
I can hardly wait.
I'm sorry we didn't
realize we were in the way.
While you're settling the details, you don't mind
if I take this woman out and buy her a ring, do you?
Sure, go ahead, we want everything legal.
That's a charming match.
A nice girl like Vicky.
And public nuisance number one.
Now wait a minute,
Norman's alright.
And if you'll pardon my pointing,
Vickie's business is her own.
It doesn't require any comment.
I wasn't making any comments.
I just said it's a rotting shame.
So go ahead and plan the elopement.
Oh that elopement stuff is out.
You can't get any scope in that.
We are going to have a wedding.
Where will we have it?
Customary place I believe is a church.
Nah.
Been done.
This gotta be something big.
The beach.
I can visualize it.
The bridesmaids in bathing suits.
Twenty thousand Santa
Monica school children.
Filling out the word love.
It's a novelty, but is it big enough?
Why not the city hall?
A police escort.
Every motorcycle cop in town.
Sirens screaming. Confetti
pouring out of buildings.
Like the Lindbergh reception in New York.
Only on a big scale.
What's the matter? Isn't it big enough?
And now if any man can show just cause
why these two may not
be lawfully joined together
let him now speak, or else
hereafter forever hold his peace.
Do you
Alfred Henkle
take this woman as your lawful wedded wife?
Will you love, comfort, honor and
keep her in sickness and in health?
As long as you both shall live?
I will. Do you
I beg your pardon.
Do you Esther Blodget take
this man as you your lawful wedded husband?
Will you obey, serve, love, honor
and keep him in sickness and in health?
As long as you both shall live?
I will.
Place the ring on her finger.
And hurry please.
Now by virtues of the power invested in me
as justice of the peace of
I pronounce you man and wife.
Quiet!
And now I must exercise
my prerogative of office.
I hope you'll be very happy Mrs. Hinkle.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you very much.
Now if you will please sign the license.
Oh, oh yeah.
You know ahh.. Mrs. Hinkle...
I can't help but believe I've
seen you somewhere before.
Oh really?
Oh well, uh, I believe this is the
first time I've ever been in San Bardo.
You know your face is familiar
too. Really? Here you are.
Thank you very much.
Well thank you.
Thank you
Good bye.
Norm!
Nice to see you again...
No I just... coming darling.
Ya I think he got by with it.
But it was closed
J.P. was just beginning to
remember where he'd seen it.
Anyway we got away from Libby
Hello, Sir!
If you would be kind enough to
glance between my shoulder blades.
Mr. and Mrs. Hankle.
You will find there a knife.
Buried to the hilt.
On the handle are your initials.
Really good seeing you Libby!
Hold it Danny!
There comes a couple
of rats I raised from mice.
Well, they've got a right
to get married haven't they?
You haven't got any right
to double cross the public.
I haven't done it yet
Hey!
People vs. Porky Washington.
Who is charge with violating section 600...
Now your in contempt of court!
Operator?
Los Angeles Tribune
I have a good mind to put you under arrest!
Wait till i make this call
you wait too
Tribune!
Give me the city desk.
Johnny!
This is Matt Libby
I've got a flash for you.
Norman Maine and Vicki Lester
were married at 2:30 this afternoon.
Vicki Lester?!
Court recess!
So give me a horse... a great big horse...
A great big buckeroo and
let me waohoo, waohoo, waohoo!
Wahoo!
Waohoo.
I don't want to sound immodest
but i think I've stripped a gear
Well sit down won't you
and let's get acquainted.
Probably be seeing quite a
bit of each other from now on.
Might just as well break
the ice now as later
now we're old friends
hey, have i got time for
a shower before dinner?
Plenty, if you can find a shower
i never can remember where that thing is
it pull out or slide under?
Here, i think i can find it
nope, that's the linen closet
here it is
Nice work.
Half the time those things are just luck
ill see if i can disinfect this steak
Hey Esther.
Uh, there's no soap.
Here.
Oh and Esther!
Yes.
I'll need a washcloth please
How you fix the cigarettes?
You know I never smoke underwater.
What do I do to make this thing work?
Pull that gadget at the
top and pray for rain.
Oh I...
i cant reach it, i cant get my hands up!
You go in there with your arms
down you'll never get your bath.
Unless you're a contortionist
yea well, i..i'm not a contortionist
and don't throw that up to me now
you knew it, when you married me
close this door please
Thank you.
OH... ow
Norman, Norman! Here comes the car.
You gotta...
Huh?
Here, quick!
Quick what?
Quick go out and stop
them and ask for help.
I'll catch a cold!
Get warm again.
They'll recognize me
not if you keep your face down!
Go on, there may not
be another car for weeks!
Oh I...
ah..ah..howdy partner!
Howdy..ah
stuck?
Yeah, how'd you guess it?
Can you get us some help?
Well, I reckon not.
You know it's a long way to town,
We're pretty busy down at that place.
Well, I got to get out of
here I got my wife with me.
She like the country?
No.
And we're short of food.
There's a lot of game in them woods
well my wife can't shoot
Well your sure up against it.
Sorry I can't do anything
for you.
Wait listen I'll be frank with you.
I'm Norman Maine.
Who?
Norman Maine!
My name is Jett Baker
Glad to have met you.
Well so long.
Hey wait a..wait a
minute..listen..you don't
So you are Norman Maine.
I've got my prestige to look out for.
I'm supposed to be the best
publicity man in the racket
And they laughed
themselves sick when I even
try to get a decent mention of me.
Yes, i know how sensitive you are Libby.
I don't like to see your feelings hurt
Thanks boss.
Now Vicki,
there's a dish for free space
but if Maine swam across the Pacifi
the papers would keep it a secret
Well,
the exhibitors don't like him,
the critics don't like him,
the public don't like him,
and I don't like him.
Who likes him?
Oh but darling, this is almost too much.
There i was in my touching innocence
thinking we were going
to live in the beach house
oh, we'll still keep a place at malibu
this is special, this is our
castle. It used to be in the air
we will never use any ugly words like,
contracts and pictures and careers
When we come in those gates,
Check the studio outside.
Come on I got another
little surprise for you.
Oh Norman it's lovely.
So are you, lovely
The whole world is lovely.
Hey! Hold it!
That's it.
Caption!
Their honeymoon never ends.
Alright, let's get some pictures.
Now the bride will sit here.
And the groom stand behind her.
You have something unique.
Now lets go after something different
You sit down and she'll stand up.
Pretty radical isn't it?
Yea, but in a nice way
Ok Otto fire!
Caption. Their honeymoon begins a new.
Wow, the producer.
Caption. Their honeymoon ceases abruptly.
Hello Oliver
Oh I'm glad your back.
Vicki, how well you're lookng.
Hello Oliver.
Am I interrupting?
Yes, thank you.
Just want a couple more pictures
that's enough of both of them
what they're asking for are
exclusives of Miss Lester
alone!
Oh i see
come on Oliver, let you
and me get exclusive
see you later Vicky
don't worry, my camera
smashing days are over
danger only days are over
hold that Miss Lester
gorgeous!
Oliver!
How's the dividend situation?
Very pleasant, i think we sold
two million on our next quarter
smart move of mine to sell my stock eh?
Oh well, when you need money you need it
some people save up for just such an event
there's bound to be a
rainy day occasionally
Well as a citizen of California,
I've always refused to admit that
I know, but still it does rain
well anyways, you can thank me
for some of those dividends of yours
can't you?
That was a little too quick Oliver
Well then... Chanadora
was a smash hit wasn't he?
They made Vicky a star overnight
how about me?
Well lets talk about
business at the office Norman
beautiful pool you have here
no, lets talk about it here
do they like me?
Maybe the part wasn't just right
look, Oliver
you think I'm slipping?
Can you take it?
The tense is wrong. You're
not slipping, you've slipped.
My fan mail is still big.
Norman, Norman, fan will write
to anybody with a photograph.
It only costs 3 cents for a stamp, and that
makes photographs cheaper than wallpaper
But every 25 cents they pay for a theater
ticket buys them the right to be a critic.
And your last few performances
Norman, have not pleased your critics
you remember i told you I'd uh...
be ready for the curtains
when the time came?
Well here it is.
Let's call off the
contract, no hard feelings
we're not quitting. Either of us
there is no explaining these things
we've all seen how the public
turns. Maybe we can turn them back
I've got a swell skit lined up for you
about... about Esther
uh..
You think that i'm going to get in her way
well as a matter of fact as it happens,
there's no part in the story for her
I'd more or less planned to
star her in a picture of her own
With uh..that young Pemberton opposite her
he's coming along nicely
good for young Pemberton
alright Oliver... let's make a
try at it. Lets hope it's not too late
Get with the Oliver Niles Productions
No argument... I'd buy those.
Screens most finished actor... haha.. I'll say
he's finished... He keeps them a way in droves.
Hello
no... no Miss Lester isn't home as yet
no I am not the butler
but I can take a message
just as well as he can honestly
Oh... Is that you Norman? Swell!
Listen Norman this is Arty Carver
How are you kid? Swell. Say I
hear your thru with Oliver Niles...
That on the Level?
Oh please Arty I'm not
news anymore forget it.
Say what kind of a settlement
did you make on your contract?
Give me a figure so I can do a story on it.
No money involved...
we just called it quits.
Ok, Ok, I'll fill in my own figure.
Say by the way. I've been trying to get an interview
with Vicky for two weeks but she's always busy...
How about you give an old pal a
break by speaking to her for me?
Sure I'll ask her.
Swell. So long. Heh
I didn't mean to be late darling
but Kacy wanted me... It's all right.
Your here now.
What's new today?
Nothing... Haven't been out of the house.
Lets go somewhere tonight.
Oh no no your tired we'll stay in.
I'm not tired really.
Oh you are... you've got
a hard day ahead of you...
anyway I see you little of you
I'd like to have you to myself..
Oh but it's the servents night out and we
haven't any dinner made... Yes we have...
I fix a little snake with
my own lily white hands.
Hey ah...
I'm learning to cook in my spare
time. Then I think I'll marry you..
Oh I get it.
You want to make an honest cook of me huh?
Comes in on wheels in this joint.
Here you are... how's it look?
Hmm... wonderful!
That's what I thought.
Now there don't be formal just pitch in.
Here you are.
I'm afraid my mouths not quite big enough.
I'll measure next time
and make them to size.
A little hard to nip too.
I'll take the hint... I'll take
those measurements right now.
That's what I wait for...
That's why I rush home without
even changing my costume.
Wait.. We're forgetting that we're
hungry... Would you like a sandwich?
No Thank you I still have
a little work on this one.
Now... Oh... Heh...
Norman will you unhook
my dress, I can't breathe
And all the time I thought it was
the kiss that made you breathless.
A lot of hooks, why
don't you have a zipper?
Good idea
feel better?
Don't look now but uh...
I think that guy on your
left is in love with you
Door bell. Is it?
Maybe they'll go away.
Oh they never do at a time like this.
Just a minute dear... I'll be right back.
Does Vicky Lester live here?
I've got a package for her
and who are you?
I'm her husband
Sign right here Mr.Lester
package for you
by the way i forgot to tell you uh...
they want you for a benefit shrine
auditorium next Wednesday night
told them i'd ask you
darling, i don't want
to hear about that now
you better wait till i finish
before i forget them all
uhm.. the academy dinner secretary phoned
she wants to know if you
want a table reserved for you
Oh Yes Arty Carver called and ask if I'd use
my influence with you to get him an interview.
I told him I'd try. Ah
that was all I think.
Oh Norman please don't
talk about those things now.
We're forgetting the
wonderful food you prepared.
Hmm... I'm not very
hungry now... I think I'll ah...
I'll fix a little drink. Hmm...
Norm...
I wish Norman would come.
Stop worrying.
Think how nice that statue is
going to look on your mantle piece.
You suppose anythings happened to him?
Of course not, he's just been held up in
traffic. You just think about that statuette.
Now we arrive at the climax of the annual dinner of
the Academy of Motion Picture of Arts and Science.
The highest award within
our power to bestow.
We've already uploaded with
our harts as well as our hands.
While awards have been
given those gentleman
who during the past year have rendered distinguished
service to the motion picture industry.
We now pay honour to the ladies.
Or rather to one lady.
We offer to her the academy award of
the finest performance of the past year.
She has already had the world's acclaim
but this is the tribute
of our fellow workers,
the men and women of this industry.
It is not only my pleasure but my privilege
to give this award to the actress who created the
unforgettable actress of Anna in Green without end.
Miss Vicky Leicester.
What more can we say miss
Leicester. This says it all for us.
Lady's and gentlemen's! When something
like this happens to you and you try to
count how you feel
about it, you find out that
Out of the all the words in
the world there are only two
words that would mean anything:
Thank you! All I can do is to
say them to you from my heart.
All I can do is
All I can do is keep on saying them...
Hey! That's fine. All this thing. Please! That's
a very pretty speech my dear. Very pretty!
You said what I think. I
wanna be the very first
I wanna be the very first
to congratulate you. But..
I'm not a valuable piece of...
Now I wanna make a speech.
Gentleman of the Academy and fellow suckers
I got one of those for the best performance, they
don't mean a thing. People get them every year.
What I want is a special award.
Something nobody else can get.
I wanna statue of the worst
performance of the year.
In fact I want three statues.
For the three worst performances of
the year, because I've earned them.
And every single one of you
that saw those last masterpieces
of mine knows I've earned them.
Liby start the music.
What I'm here to find out is,
do I get 'em or do I get 'em?
As or yes or no? ♪splash ♪
Come on darling! Let's put on some ice!
Come on Owen put some aid!
That's clear Owen. Hello, Norman!
Hi! How are you? Hi, Owen!
Hi Owen! My dear,
My dear do let me congratulate
you. You must be very proud
You must be very proud and happy tonight.
Thank you!
Tony give me a drink!
Albert nice of you to come to my
venue. Vicky how are you? I missed you!
Everyone missed you! Had a nice trip?
Well the three months tour that get
us out of... because of out of pleasure
But the way they were screaming
for your pictures all over the country,
Esleka if I may talk shot you are Enaka.
Thank you! Is good to hear that.
You've been crying. A little
A little. How is Norman?
How is Norman?
Rough he's trying hard for all of us.
Letting Norman leave the studio was the hardest
thing I ever do. There was nothing else I could do.
There was nothing else I could do. I know.
I know. Have you been.
Have you been .. Is he alright?
He got to the sanatarium
He really wanted that prix.
Now I think he could only...
Well, I'll have to start working
again, it'll be some encouragement.
Oliver, could you... could you do that?
Oh, thank you. But he
mustn't ever know I told you.
He won't know, and you mustn't worry. I
want you to keep up your good work in this
It's the one thing I can do for you.
If you'll just sit here, Mr.Niles, I'll have Mr. Maindorf down.
- Thank you.
Or not.
Hello Oliver! Welcome to Liberty Hall.
Hello Norman. Well,
This is just a handshake
This is Cuddle, Oliver,
my social secretary.
We, we go everywhere together.
How're you feeling Norman? Alright?
I'm getting on remarkably well,
You oughta see some of the boys.
Go sit down.
Cuddles, we really don't need you.
Are you comfortable here, Norman?
- Comfortable? It's positively luxurious.
They even have iron bars on the
windows to keep out the drought.
How much longer are you gonna be here?
Hang on for the next week
or two to get in good shape.
After all, there is no particular
hurry to return to the cameras.
That's what I wanted to talk to you about. I've
got a script with a fine part for you in it.
Ah well that's great. That's great.
Who... who plays opposite me?
Well, it is not exactly the lead.
Young Pimberton's doing that, but I tell you
frankly I find your part better than the lead.
Huh. I see.
Better than the lead?
Of course it isn't terribly long,
but it's one of those parts that
makes an impression on you.
They'll be thinking about you all through the picture.
- Uh huh.
Well, the thing is Oliver, I'm, uh,
pretty well settled at another studio.
And I'm not at liberty at the moment to tell you
which one, you know yourself how those things are.
Big picture, One of the
biggest of the year and the part
every actor in Hollywood
will give his teeth to play.
Well that's fine Norman, and naturally, that would tie you up
for a while, but we won't get to this picture for some time,
and perhaps, if you want
to consider it for later on,
Well, I tell ya Oliver, you
better not count on me.
See, I've got several pictures lined up after
this, and then they're talking to me about England
You know, they're doing some
very interesting things over there
Hey
What is it? Cuddle speak
right out. We all love you.
The dinner.
- Oh!
We dine at five thirty here,
makes the nights longer.
Now, goodbye Norman. I'm glad
to see you're getting along so well.
I'll be out in no time.
I'll have to introduce myself all over to a lot
of people, won't know when I'm not drinking.
Goodbye.
- Goodbye.
Goodbye Norman.
- Thanks for dropping in.
Well, cuddles... alone at last.
Christmas Week
Racing
Santa Anita Park
Oh, hello.
-Hello
Hello, Norman.
I see.
How I hate to run into these has-beens.
Give me the creeps.
Me too.
He was good while he had it.
And he had it quite a while.
-Hello
-Hello Mr. Maine
- I haven't seen you in a long time.
- Ah, I've been resting
Ginger ale, please.
Ginger ale and what?
Ginger ale and ginger ale.
New leaf?
A whole new book.
Thank you.
Scotch straight.
Hello Libby
Why it's Mr. America of yesteryear.
Do they let you wander
about now without a keeping?
I didn't expect to find you an Santa Anita.
What do they do with the
actors when you're away?
Oh, they cut them into
slices and fry them with eggs.
Suppose you'll be here all the time
Now that you've retired from
the hurly-burly of the silver screen.
Well, I'm living down in Malibu now. Pretty
lonesome with Esther away working all day.
I wouldn't squawk about that if I were you.
It's nice having somebody
in the family making a living.
Oh Well, I'm gonna tell you.
I don't want to forget that we're friends.
Friends my eye. Say listen
I got you out of your jams because I had to,
it was my job not because I was your friend.
I don't like you and I never have
liked you. Nothing made me happier
than to see all those cute little pranks of yours has finally
catch up with you and land you on your celebrated face!
Pretty work, Libby. Always wait
till they're down, then kick them.
I don't feel sorry for you. You've
fixed yourself nice and comfortable.
You can live off your wife now. She'll buy you drinks
and put up with you even though nobody else will.
Wait a minute, Wait a minute...
Come on outside for your right, pal!
I am Norman Maine!
Oh, Don't bother to throw him out.
- He's harmless.
- Alright, Mr. Libby if you say so.
We should let him go, What can he do?
He can't fight any better that he can act.
Norman Maine...
Give me Scotch... double.
Leave the bottle here.
Vicki, you'll be ill.
Why don't you try to get some sleep?
He's been gone 4 days,
4 days and not a word.
Oliver I can't.
Hello? No, this is Oliver
Niles speaking. What? Where?
Thank you.
What is it?
Nothing, nothing.
Oliver tell me.
He's in the night court. He's been arrested on a drunk charge and
he's alright, isn't hurt and I'm going right now to get him out.
I'm going with you.
Vicki, is isn't many place for
you and if it gets in the paper-
What I care about the
paper? I'm going with you!
Precinct 30, Municipal Court
County Los Angeles.
The honorable judge Jeff Harris presiding.
Be seated, Please.
Oliver, did you do anything?
The judge wouldn't even see me.
Ready, Your honor.
I want to advise you that you are entitled
to be represented by counsel,
to be confronted by the witnesses
that may testified against you,
To compel witnesses
to attend on your behalf
to the public and a speedy
trial by the court, by a jury
and the right to place a bail.
Call the first five.
Gregory, Railes, Maine, Rodríguez, Johnson
Come on, Let's go!
Go ahead, Move Along.
-William Gregory
-Yes
Plain drunk, picked up in fifth and towne
Sleeping in the gutter, 14 similar
offenses in the past 6 months.
Still at it, Gregory? How do you plead?
I don't feel so good.
I didn't ask how you feel,
I ask you how you plead?!
Guilty, I guess.
When did you get out the last time?
Day before christmas.
I'm sorry. You'll have to miss New Years. You should
be out in time for Washington's birthday. Sixty days.
Milton Railes
Plain drunk,
Picked up im Brooklyn avenue, giving treatment
at residence hospital, then removed to jail.
How old are you, Railes?
Uh, seventeen, sir.
Did you get a good look at those
men in the cell with you last night?
Yes, sir.
Have you taken a good
look at yourself this morning?
Well, no sir.
Well, I suggest that you do.
Five dollars and two days.
Sentence suspended.
Oh, judge! I...
Alfred Henckle!
Commonly Known as Norman Maine.
Drinking disorderly, Wreck a car
into a tree in Sunset and Coronado.
Evidently been drinking for days, Resisted
arrest and injured one of the arresting officers.
How do you plead?
Guilty.
You're Norman Maine, the actor, aren't you?
You've come pretty low, haven't you?
There isn't a man here who's had the advantages
you've had. Look what you've done with them.
You're nothing but an irresponsible drunk, Driving above the streets
with the power to inflict death or injury to innocent people.
We better deny you that power for a while.
Ninety days in the city jail.
Please wait.
I'm his wife.
Yes, I recognized you Ms. Lester.
Please, Judge. I promise
you, this won't happen again.
I'll be responsible for him... if
you just won't send him there.
Do you realize that this man, when drunk,
is obviously a menace to public safety?
And you realized too Ms. Lester,
the responsibility you'll
be assuming to this court...
I do.
Sentence suspended.
Prisioner remanded to custody of wife.
You can meet him at
the jail entrance madam.
José Rodriguez
Found drunk, picked up first of maine.
Second offense.
-How do you plead?
-I think I'm guilty, your honor
-Sixty days
I'm...
- I'm so tired.
- Hold it, Mr. Maine, a picture.
- Oh no, Please. -What about a picture to the press?
- Oh no, Please.
Norman Maine Released to custody of Vicki Lester after drunk
Conviction! Night court Drama as star Pleads for husband's freedom.
He's still asleep. He's
been asleep all day.
That's the best thing for him.
Is awful to see this
happen to someone you love
and know in your heart
that can't get any better.
All I know that, All I can do now is stay
with him and try to help him.
So am I.
Take care of him.
You'll very fond of him aren't you Oliver.
I'm very fond of both.
Then I know you'll understand
what I have to tell you.
After what happen last night, I think you already
know what it is. I can't do any more pictures.
I'm going away for good with Norman.
You can't do that Vicki, You're in the very peak
of your success and you work so hard to achieve.
This is for Norman, I thought it all out
I know it's too late to
think about that now.
But...
May not too be late to go away
with him and star over somewhere.
It's your life your giving up Vicki.
So I can try to get norman back his.
Can you honestly tell
me I'm wrong to do it.
No Vicki, I can't honestly tell you that.
Then there'll be no more Vicki Lester.
Come on, walk to the door with me.
Goodbye, Vicki Lester.
You were a grand girl.
Good luck, Mrs. Norman Maine.
Darling!
Maine coming in to apologize again.
Stop, I'm sorry Dear, but
It isn't you
What other troubles have you got?
None.
I was just playing a scene with myself.
Now look, I'm just coming out of the
jitters and your just going into them.
This is swell housefold.
Isn't it?
Tell you what we'll do. I promise
to brace up, you go on the wagon.
I cannot have been drinking too mch.
What I'm gonna do, I'm
going to be an athlete.
You mean with great big
muscles and everything.
Well, roughly speaking.
Gonna join the YMCA?
No, cost too much. Now I'm
going waiting out on the front yard.
-Now
-Sure!
Do you like me to go with you?
Sure, if you like to.
Norman, I don't think I will.
It might spoil this beatiful natural waves.
Yeah, I get that's right.
Darling, look.
Can I have a hot...
I mean some hot soup
for me, when I come back?
A hot soup.
And I make one some
of those nice sandwiches.
Norman, do you have to?
- Come on now.
- Don't stay out too long
Hey!
Do you mind if I take
just... one more look?
Norman Maine's body found of Malibu
Ex-Star perishes in tragic accident!
First drink of water he had in twenty
years. Then, he had to get it by accident.
But how do you write
congratulations to the Pacific Ocean?
There he is now!
Oh! You can't see a thing.
Hello Vicki!
- Get away, can't you?
- Come on, Vicki! Let's see your face.
Vicki, will you sign my book for me?
Write "This is Norman Maine".
Don't you care, Vicki. You'll get over it.
Stand back, can't you?
Don't you cry, dearie! He wasn't so much!
Do you mind if I take
just... one more look?
Here are the paychecks
for the servants, Graves.
You'll find a very nice bonus in each one.
Miss Nasta asked me to thank
you for your kindness and service.
If there is anything i can do for the
little lady, i should be glad to do it.
She would appreciate
your attending to the??
Be careful with that!
Put it down, I say!
Well? Where is she?
I-In the bedroom, who are you?
Oh, I'm her grandmother.
Get out of the way!
Hey
Granny, darling!
Oh I'm so glad to see
you. What made you come?
Oh I know when I'm needed.
Now get out of here! Go
on, get out of here, all of you!
I want to talk to my grand-daughter alone.
I came just as quickly as i could.
But I'm going home. I
sent you a ride yesterday.
Hm! Sit down!
Is it true that you're
going to uit the movie?
I never want to hear them again.
What"re you running away from?
I'm not running away.
It's just that i can't go on.
My heart isn't there anymore.
Once i told you to get what you want
to have to give your heart in exchange
And you said, you will win, remember?
I remember.
Seems to me that you got more
than you were bargaining for.
More fame. More success.
Even more, personal happiness.
Maybe, more unhappiness.
But you did make a bargain
and now you're whining over it.
I don't think i'd feel so very
proud of myself, if i were you
I'm not Granny, my mind's made up
But Granny-
I was proud of you Esther.
I was proud to be the
grandmother of Esther.
It gave me something to
live for. Now, I haven't any.
I know. i wanna be
strong but I can't go on.
You must. Tragedy is a test of courage.
If you can meet it bravely, it will
leave you bigger than it found you.
If not, then you'll have to
live all your life as a coward.
Because no matter where you may
run, you can never run away from yourself.
I never knew Norman Maine.
He wrote me a very sweet
letter when you were married.
He said you told him
how much I meant to you.
And I know just how much
you must meant to him.
You know, Esther. I can't
believe that whenever you meet
he can be very happy
knowing that he just broke the spirit
of the little girl he praised me so highly
and I can't believe that
he can be very proud
knowing that all the great love is to you
was to make me a Putter
The car is ready Ms. Esther. You'll
have to go now to make the train.
Put the car back in the garage.
The girl who has won
the heart of Hollywood.
the heart of the world.
Ms. Vicki Lester!
And if i'm not mistaken, Ms.
Lester's car has just been arrived.
Yes, it is here!
I scare very slowly, young man!
Smile folks, please!
They'll have your mug-
I mean, your face plastered across half
the papers in the country tomorrow
- Hm how do i look?
Oh you look well
You're a liar, but I like ya.
And here Mrs. Lester Grandmother.
Would you say a few words
to the radio audience, please?
Say something, lady
You know, we've got a thing like that back home where
they all listen You know but we call it a pathy-line
Won't you say something,
please? They're listening.
Maybe some of you people listening
in dream about coming to Hollywood.
Maybe some of you will
get pretty discouraged.
Well, when you do, you just think about me.
It took me over seventy...
Sixty years to get here, but here I am
and here I mean to stay.
Thank you very much.
Miss Lester
This microphone is on
an international hookup.
Throughout the world, your fans are hoping
that you'll say a few words to them.
Hello, everyone...
This is Mrs. Norman Maine.